foreign
data generated by companies and
individuals like us has grown massively
over the past decade as per statista.com
the global data are generated and
consumed would reach 181 zettabytes by
2025. organizations need to gather and
analyze such large volumes of data and
look at their past business performances
as well as results and use that
information to prepare for the future
that essentially is data analytics so
hey everyone welcome to this interesting
video tutorial of data analytics full
course 2022 by simply learned this video
will help you gain all the necessary
skills and knowledge within 12 hours to
become a data analyst in 2022 our
experienced trainers will take you
through the course but before we begin
if you love watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an update from
us so let's look at the topics we'll be
learning in this video
we'll start by understanding the basics
of data analytics and learn the top 10
data analyst skills for 2022. after that
we learned the top 10 data analysis
tools followed by looking at a use case
in Python
next you'll get an idea of how to
manipulate and visualize data using our
packages and then look at time series
analysis in R then we'll shift our Focus
to understanding data analytics using
Excel pivot tables and learn to create
Excel dashboards moving further you'll
see some interesting data analytics
projects related to coronavirus Spotify
World happiness report and Olympics
finally we will learn some of the
important questions that are asked
frequently in data analytics interviews
so let's get started hi guys
welcome to another video tutorial by
simply loan in today's session
we will look at data analytics for
beginners
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to another mission update
in this video
we will discuss what data analytics is
and the need for data analytics
then we will look at the different ways
in which data analytics can be used
followed by the various steps involved
in the data analytics process
after that
we will get an idea about the different
tools used in data analytics and the
company is using data analytics
moving forward we will see a case study
on how Walmart uses data analytics for
better customer service and finally we
will perform a regression analysis in R
to predict sales based on the
advertising expenditure from three
mediums tv ads radio ads and newspaper
advertisements
so what is data analytics
companies around the world are
generating vast volumes of data every
hour this data could be in the form of
log files web server and transactional
data as well as various customer related
data also data has been generated at a
rapid rate from social media websites
and applications such as Facebook
Instagram Twitter and WhatsApp
companies want to use this data to
derive value out of it and make business
decisions
that's where data analytics comes into
use
data analytics is the process of
exploring and analyzing large data sets
to find hidden patterns unseen Trends
discover correlations and valuable
insights to make business predictions
data analytics improves the speed and
efficiency of your business
a few years ago a business would have
gathered information manually performed
statistical and complex analytics and
Unearthed information that could be used
for future decisions
but today that business can identify
insights on the Fly for immediate
decisions
most organizations have big data and
many understand the need to harness that
data and extract value out of it
so they use a lot of modern tools and
Technologies to perform data analytics
some of the tools I will discuss in
detail later in this tutorial
now that we have looked at what data
analytics really is let us understand
the ways in which you can use data
analytics
first is improved decision making
data analytics eliminates a lot of
guesswork and manual tasks from choosing
the right content planning marketing
campaigns and developing products
organizations can use the insights they
gain from data analytics to make
informed decisions leading to better
outcomes and customer satisfaction
it gives you a 360 degree view of your
customers which helps you understand the
behavior completely enabling you to
better meet their needs
second is better customer service
data analytics provides you with more
accurate insights of your customers
allowing you to tailor customer service
to their needs provide more
personalization and build stronger
relationships with them
your data can reveal information about
your customers communication preferences
their interests their concerns and more
it helps you give better recommendations
for products and services
next is efficient operations
data analytics can help you streamline
your processes save money and boost
production
when you have an improved understanding
of what your audience wants
you waste less time in creating ads and
content that don't match your audience
interests this helps you optimize your
campaigns create better content
strategies and hence improve results
and finally we have effective marketing
when you understand your audience better
you can Market to them more effectively
data analytics also gives you useful
insights into how your campaigns are
performing so that you can fine tune
them for optimal outcomes
you also find out the probable customers
who are the most likely to interact with
a campaign and convert into leads
now let's discuss the various steps
involved in the data analytics process
as you can see on the screen there are
five process steps now let me make you
understand each of this one by one
so the first step is to understand the
problem
before starting with the analysis you
need to understand the business problem
and Define your goals asking questions
at the outlet is vital because this
would address issues such as how can we
reduce production costs without
sacrificing quality what are some of the
ways to increase sales opportunities
with our current resources
do customers view our brand in a
favorable way answers to these questions
will help you build a clear road map
with new Creative Solutions
also try to find out the key performance
indicators and consider the Matrix to
track along the way
the second step in the process is data
collection
after you have finalized your goals it's
time to start looking for your data
data collection is the process of
gathering information on targeted
variables identified as data
requirements
the emphasis is on ensuring accurate and
right data is collected data collection
starts with primary sources which are
also known as internal sources this is
typically structured data gathered from
CRM software Erp systems marketing
automation tools and others these
sources contain information about
customers finances gaps in sales
Etc
under external sources you have both
structured and unstructured data so if
you are looking to perform a sentiment
analysis towards your brand you would
gather data from various review websites
or social media apps
the next step is to clean the data
the data which is collected from various
sources is highly likely to contain
incomplete duplicate and missing values
so you need to clean these unwanted
redundant data to make it ready for
analysis
so to generate accurate results
analytics professionals must identify
duplicate and analyst data another
inconsistencies that could skew the
analysis according to a report sixty
percent of data scientists say most of
the time is spent cleaning the data
while 57 percent of data scientists say
it's their least enjoyable task
now the fourth step in the process is
data exploration and Analysis
once data is cleaned and ready you can
go ahead and explore the data using data
visualization and business intelligence
tools
you can also use various Data Mining and
predictive modeling techniques to
analyze the data and build models
you can use different supervised and
unsupervised algorithms such as linear
regression logistic regression decision
tree k n k-means clustering and lots
more to build prediction models for
making business decisions
and the final step is to interpret the
results
this part is important because it's how
a business will gain actual value from
the previous four steps
interpreting the results will help you
find unseen Trends and patterns in the
data and gain insights you can have a
validation check if the results are
answering your questions these results
can be shown to your clients and
stakeholders for better understanding
and business collaboration
now that we have looked at the various
steps involved in data analytics let's
now see the different tools that can be
used to perform the above steps
so as you can see we have seven tools
including a few programming languages
that will help you perform analytics
better now let's discuss them one by one
first we have python
python is an object oriented open source
programming language that supports a
range of libraries for data manipulation
data visualization and data modeling
python programmers have developed tons
of free and open source libraries that
you can use
you can find many of them via the python
package index which is py the repository
of python software
python provides the default package
installer called pip or pip
python has libraries such as numpy for
numerical computation of data pandas to
manipulate data on numerical tables and
time series then you have scipy for
Technical and scientific computations it
also provides scikit-learn which is a
machine learning library for creating
classification regression and clustering
algorithms and finally it also has pi
torch and tensorflow for deep learning
up next we have r
R is an open source programming language
majorly used for numerical and
statistical analysis it provides a range
of libraries for data analysis and
visualization some of these libraries
are ggplot Thai DeVos plotly deployer
and carrot
then we have tableau
Tableau is a popular data visualization
and analytics tools that helps you
create a range of visualizations to
interactively present the data build
reports and dashboards to Showcase
insights and Trends it can connect with
multiple data sources and give hidden
business insights and patterns
then we have a competitor of Tableau
which is power bi
power bi is a business intelligence tool
developed by Microsoft that has an easy
drag and drop functionality and supports
multiple data sources with features that
make data visually appealing
power bi supports features that help you
ask questions to your data and get
immediate insights you can also forecast
your data for predicting future trends
so the next tool is Click View
click view provides interactive
analytics with in-memory storage
technology to analyze vast volumes of
data and use data discoveries to support
decision making
it provides social media Discovery and
interactive guided Analytics
it can manipulate huge data sets
instantly with accuracy
up next we have Apache Spark
Apache spark is an open source data
analytics engine to process data in real
time and Carry Out complex analytics
using SQL queries and machine learning
algorithms
it supports spark streaming for
real-time analytics and Spark SQL for
writing SQL queries
it also has spark ml lib which is a
library that has a repository of machine
learning algorithms and then it has
graphics for graphical computation
and finally we have SAS
SAS is a statistical analysis software
that can help you perform analytics
visualize your data write SQL queries
perform statistical analysis and build
machine learning models to make future
predictions SAS empowers our customers
to move the world forward by
transforming data into intelligence
SAS is investing a lot to drive software
Innovation for Analytics Gartner has
positioned SAS as a magic quadrant
leader for data science and machine
learning
moving on to the applications of data
analytics
data analytics has been used to learn
most every sector of business these days
let's discuss a few of them
first we have retail
customers expect retailers to understand
exactly what they need and when they
need it
data analytics helps retailers meet
those demands
retailers not only have an in-depth
understanding of their customers but
they can also predict Trends recommend
new products and boost profitability
retailers create assortments based on
customer preferences invoke the most
relevant engagement strategy for each
customer optimize supply chain and
Retail operations at every step of the
customer Journey
the second application is on Healthcare
Healthcare Industries analyze patient
data to provide life-saving diagnosis
and treatment options
they also deal with healthcare plans and
insurance information to drive key
insights using analytics they can
discover new drugs and come up with new
drug development methods
Advanced analytics allows healthcare
companies to improve patient outcomes
and experience
cancer cells and diabetic retinopathy
can be discovered using Medical Imaging
at number three we have Manufacturing
for manufacturers solving problem is
nothing new
they fight with difficult problems and
situations on a daily basis
from complex Supply chains to motion
applications to labor constraints and
Equipment breakdowns they deal with such
problems on a regular basis
using data analytics manufacturing
sectors can discover new cost saving and
revenue opportunities
the fourth application is related to the
banking sector
Banking and financial institutions
collect vast volumes of structured and
unstructured data to derive analytical
insights and make sound financial
decisions
using analytics they can find out
probable loan defaulters customer
churnout rate and detect fraudulent
transactions immediately
the final application is based on
Logistics
logistics companies use data analytics
to develop new business models that can
ease their business and improve
productivity
they can optimize routes to ensure
delivery reaches on time in a cost
efficient manner they also focus on
improving order processing capabilities
as well as Performance Management
with that
now let's look at the companies using
data analytics on a daily basis
so if we have the e-commerce giant
Amazon
then we have Accenture followed by the
American healthcare service organization
Cigna
then we have the American supplier of
Health Information Technology Solutions
Services devices and Hardware sonar
followed by Target and Antivirus company
maccafe
next we have Rapido which is an Indian
bike rental company based in Bangalore
after that we have Flipkart and the
world's largest retail company Walmart
so sky's the limit on what you use it
for let's take a look at types of data
analytics
in this can be broken up in so many ways
but we're going to start with looking at
the most basic questions that you're
going to be asking in data analytics and
the first one is you want descriptive
analytics what has happened hindsight
how many cells per call ratio coming out
of the call center if we have 500
tourists in a forest and you have a
certain temperature how many fires were
started how many times did the police
have to show up to certain houses all
that's descriptive the next one is
predictive Predictive Analytics is what
will happen next we want to predict this
is great if you want to have a ice cream
store and you want to predict how many
people to work at the ice cream store on
a certain day based on the temperature
coming up in the time of the year
and then one of the biggest growing and
most important parts of the industry is
now prescriptive analytics and you can
think of that as combining the first two
we have descriptive and we have
predictive then you get
pre-scriptive Analytics
how can we make it happen foresight what
can we change to make this work better
in all the industries we looked at
before we can start asking questions
especially in City development there's a
good one
if we want to have our city generate
more income and we want that income to
be commercial based what kind of
commercial buildings do we need to build
in that area that are going to bring
people over do we need huge warehouse
sales Costco sales buildings or do we
need little mom pod joints that are
going to bring in people from the
country to come shop there or do you
want an industrial setup what do you
need to bring that into industry in
there is our car industry available in
that area if it's not a car industry
what other Industries are in that area
all those things are prescriptive we're
guessing we're guessing what can we do
to fix it what can we do to fix crime
and area with education what kind of
education are we going to use to help
people understand what's going on so
that we lower the rate of crime and we
help our communities grow better that's
all prescriptive it's all guessing we
went foresight into how can we make it
happen how can we make this better
and we really can't not go into enough
detail on these three because a lot of
people stumble on this when they come in
and are doing analytics whether you're
the manager shareholder or the data
scientist coming in you really need to
understand the descriptive analytics
where you're studying the total units of
furniture sold and the profit that was
made in the past here we go into
Predictive Analytics predicting the
total units that would sell and the
profit we can expect in the future gear
up for how many employees we need how
much money we're going to make and
prescriptive analytics finding ways to
improve the sales and the profit so we
can sell maybe a different kind of
furniture we're going to guess at what
the area is looking for and how that
marketing is going to change
hello everyone we welcome you all to
this video by simply learn in today's
session we will learn a really
interesting topic that is the top 10
skills to become a data analyst in 2022
in today's Digital World data is being
generated by companies and individuals
every second so the role of a data
analyst holds supreme importance
so if you're looking for a career in
data analytics this video will help you
learn what a data analyst does and the
various skills you need to possess to
become a data analyst in 2022
before we get started make sure you
subscribe to the simply learned Channel
and hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update from us
let's look at the agenda for this video
first we will understand who a data
analyst is then we will understand the
top 10 data analyst skills for 2022.
moving on we will look at the salary of
a data analyst and finally we will look
at the companies hiring data analysts
so now let's understand who is the data
analyst
a data analyst is a professional who
collects business data from various
sources interprets it and uses various
statistical tools and techniques to
extract insights and useful information
from it
they acquire data from primary or
secondary data sources and maintain
databases they also recognize and
understand the organization's goal and
collaborate with different team members
such as programmers business analysts
and data scientists to build an
effective solution to a business problem
now with this basic understanding of who
are data analyst is let's learn the top
10 data analyst skills for 2022.
at number one we have structured query
language or SQL SQL is a top skill that
every data analyst should have data
analysts use SQL commands and functions
to store process analyze and manipulate
structured data using relational and
nosql databases
they also build data models and write
complex SQL queries and scripts to
gather and extract information from
several databases and data warehouses
some of the popular databases a data
analyst should be familiar with are
Microsoft SQL Server MySQL postgresql
and IBM db2
the second important skill for a data
analyst is Microsoft Excel
Microsoft Excel is one of the most
popular and oldest spreadsheet
applications for creating reports
performing calculations and analyzing
data data analysts need to know how to
handle tabular data in Excel so they
should be aware of features like sorting
filtering conditional formatting pivot
tables what-if analysis and functions
such as sumifs and countifs
the third crucial data analyst skill for
2022 is data cleaning and wrangling
usually the data collected by analysts
from various heterogeneous sources is
often messy and contains a lot of
missing values
so it is always crucial to clean the
data and remove noise missing or
erroneous elements
it is also important to format data
using tools and methods before using it
for analysis
they are responsible for data mining as
well
the data mined from various sources are
organized in order to obtain new
information from it some of the tools
you need to know for data cleaning and
wrangling are Excel power query and open
refine
the fourth skill on our list is
mathematics and statistics
data analysts often work on data for
higher Dimensions that are greater than
three in order to interpret such data
they need to be good at linear algebra
and calculus they also build predictive
models and statistical models such as
linear regression logistic regression
knife base and k-means clustering in
order to understand the working of these
algorithms they must have knowledge
about statistics and probability
coming to the fifth important skill for
a data analyst in 2022 we have
programming data analysts need to master
at least one programming language
preferably python or R in order to work
with complex business problems analysts
need to write scripts and user-defined
functions to automate tedious tasks
Python and R language provide a
collection of different libraries and
packages such as numpy pandas deeply
matplotlib ggplot which data analysts
can use to discover Trends and patterns
from complex data sets
after this we have data visualization as
our sixth skill another data analyst job
role is to visualize large volumes of
data and prepare summary reports and
dashboards for the leadership team and
clients so that they can make timely
business decisions
to do this data analysts use various
data visualization tools such as power
bi Tableau and click View
using these tools data analysts can
integrate various data sets apply joint
conditions sort and filter data as well
create different visualizations using
charts and graphs
the seventh skill for a data analyst is
industry knowledge
data analysts should have good knowledge
and understanding of the industry or
domain they are working in for example
if you're working in a healthcare domain
you need to know how Healthcare
analytics can be applied to improve
patient care you should have knowledge
about the challenges faced in healthcare
and how you can leverage data and
analytics to solve the issues only if
you have strong industry knowledge can
you try to improve the business
the eighth skill that is important for a
data analyst in 2022 is problem solving
a business deals with several problems
on a daily basis data analysts should be
ready to face those challenges data
analysts are expected to use their
problem solving skills work with the
team troubleshoot what went wrong and
provide an effective solution via data
analysis
a data analyst with good problem solving
skills can help a business identify
current and potential issues and
determine a viable solution based on the
data it collects
the ninth scale on our list is
analytical thinking
data analysts need analytical thinking
ability to break down a complex problem
into simple components and resolve these
components one by one
it is a must-have skill for data
analysts
analytical thinking includes deciding
the parameters that need to be
considered for defining data sets
analyzing them from different
perspectives and determining variable
dependencies
coming to the 10th skill among the top
10 skills for a data analyst in 2022 we
have communication
data analysts don't just interact with
computers and programs they also
interact with team members stakeholders
and data suppliers
so good communication skills are
essential
data analysts also present their
findings in front of an audience who
might not be familiar with the
analytical methods and processes so they
need to clearly translate their findings
and insights into non-technical terms
so those were the top 10 skills our data
analyst needs to possess in 2022 do you
think we missed out on any skills then
please put your answers in the comment
section below
now let's look at the salary of a data
analyst
according to Glassdoor the average
annual salary for a data analyst in the
United States is 69
517 dollars while in India you can earn
nearly 7 lakh rupees per random finally
let's look at the top companies that are
hiring data analysts in 2022
here we have the consultancy and big4
giant Deloitte and the pharmaceutical
company Cerner Corporation then we have
the tech giant IBM retail company
Walmart and the e-commerce leader Amazon
to achieve the goals of data analysis we
use a number of data analysis tools
companies rely on these tools to gather
and transform their data into meaningful
insights so which tool should you choose
to analyze your data which tool should
you learn if you want to make a career
in this field we will answer that in
this session after extensive research we
have come up with these top 10 data
analysis tools here we will look at the
features of each of these tools and the
companies using them so let's start off
at number 10 we have Microsoft Excel all
of us would have used Microsoft Excel at
some point right it is easy to use and
one of the best tools for data analysis
developed by Microsoft Excel is
basically a spreadsheet program using
Excel you can create grids of numbers
text and formulas it is one of the
widely used tools be it in a small or
large setup
the interface of Microsoft Excel looks
like this
let's now move on to the features of
excel
firstly Excel works with
the windows version of excel supports
programming through Microsoft's Visual
Basic for applications VBA
programming with VBA allows spreadsheet
manipulation that is difficult with
standard spreadsheet techniques
in addition to this the user can
automate tasks such as formatting or
data organization in VBA
one of the biggest benefits of excel is
its ability to organize large amounts of
data into orderly logical spreadsheets
and charts by doing so it's a lot easier
to analyze data especially while
creating graphs and other visual data
representations the visualization can be
generated from specified group of cells
those were few of the features of
Microsoft Excel
let's now have a look at the companies
using it most of the organizations today
use Excel few of them that use it for
analysis are the UK based company Ernest
and Young then we have Urban Pro Wipro
and Amazon
moving on to our next data analysis tool
at number nine we have rapidminer
a data science software platform
rapidminer provides an integrated
environment for data preparation
analysis machine learning and deep
learning
it is used in almost every business and
Commercial sector rapidminer also
supports all the steps of the machine
learning process
seen on your screens is the interface of
rapidminer
moving on to the features of rapidminer
firstly it offers the ability to drag
and drop it is very convenient to just
drag drop some columns as you are
exploring a data set and working on some
analysis
rapidminer allows the usage of any data
and it also gives an opportunity to
create models which are used as a basis
for decision making and formulation of
strategies
it has data exploration features such as
graphs descriptive statistics and
visualization which allows users to get
valuable insights
it also has more than 1500 operators for
every data transformation and Analysis
task
let's now have a look at the companies
using rapidminer we have the Caribbean
Airline Leeward Islands Air transport
next we have the United Health Group the
American online payment company PayPal
and the Austrian Telecom company
MobileComm so that was all about
rapidminer now let's see which tool we
have at number eight
we have talent at number eight
Talent is an open source software
platform which offers data integration
and management it specializes in Big
Data integration Talent is available
both in open source and premium versions
it is one of the best tools for cloud
computing and Big Data integration
the interface of talent is as seen on
your screens
moving on to the features of talent
firstly automation is one of the great
bones Talent offers it even maintains
the tasks for the users this helps with
quick deployment and development
it also offers open source tools Talon
lets you download these tools for free
the development costs reduce
significantly as the process is
gradually speed up
Talent provides a unified platform it
allows you to integrate with many
databases SAS and other Technologies
with the help of the data integration
platform you can build flat files
relational databases and Cloud apps 10
times faster
those were the features of Talon the
companies using Talent are Air France
L'Oreal cab Gemini and the American
multinational Pisa restaurant chain
Domino's
next on the list at 7 we have nine
Constance information minor on nime is a
free and open source data analytics
reporting and integration platform
it can integrate various components for
machine learning and data mining through
its modular data pipelining concept nime
has been used in pharmaceutical research
and other areas like CRM customer data
analysis business intelligence text
Mining and financial data analysis
here is how the interface of nime
application looks like
now coming to the nine features
9 provides an interactive graphical user
interface to create visual workflows
using the drag and drop feature use of
gdbc allows assembly of nodes blending
different data sources including
pre-processing such as ETL that is
extraction transformation loading for
modeling data analysis and visualization
with minimal programming
it supports multi-threaded in-memory
data processing 9 allows users to
visually create data flows selectively
execute some or all analysis steps and
later inspect the results models and
interactive views
9 server automates workflow execution
and supports team-based collaboration
nime integrates various other open
source projects such as machine learning
algorithms from Becca H2O carers Park
and our project
nime allows analysis of 300 million
custom addresses 20 million cell images
and 10 million molecular structures
some of the companies hiring for nime
are United Health Group asml fractal
analytics atos and LEGO Group let's now
move on to the next tool we have SAS at
number six
SAS facilitates analysis reporting and
predictive modeling with the help of
powerful visualizations and dashboards
in SAS data is extracted and categorized
which helps in identifying and analyzing
data patterns
as you can see on your screens this is
how the interface looks like
moving on to the features of SAS
using SAS better analysis of data is
achieved by using automatic code
generation ads are SQL
SAS allows you to access through
Microsoft Office by letting you create
reports using it and by Distributing
them through it
SAS helps with an easy understanding of
complex data and allows you to create
interactive dashboards and reports
let's now have a look at the companies
using SAS we have companies like genpact
IQR Accenture and IBM to name a few
that was all about SAS
so for all those who joined in late let
me just quickly repeat our list at
number 10 we have Microsoft Excel then
at number nine we have rapidminer at
number eight we have talent at number
seven we have nine and at number six we
have SAS so far do you all agree with
this list let us know in the comment
section below let's now move on to the
next five Tools in our list
so at number five we have both R and
python yes we have two of them in the
fifth position
R is a programming language which is
used for analysis as well it has
traditionally been used in academics and
research python is a high level
programming language which has a python
data analysis Library it is used for
everything starting from importing data
from Excel spreadsheets to processing
them for analysis
this is the interface of r
next up is the interface of the Python
Jupiter notebook
let's now move on to the features of
both R and python
when it comes to the availability of R
and python it is very easy both are in
Python are completely free hence it can
be used without any license
I used to compute everything in memory
and hence the computations were limited
but now it has changed both are in
Python have options for parallel
computations and good data handling
capabilities
as mentioned earlier as both R and
python are open in nature all the latest
features are available without any delay
moving on to the companies using R we
have Uber Google Facebook to name a few
python is used by many companies again
to name a few we have Amazon Google and
the American photo and video sharing
social networking service Instagram
that was all about R in Python
foreign
Spark
Apache spark is an open source engine
developed specifically for handling
large-scale data processing and
Analytics
spark offers the ability to access data
in a variety of sources including Hadoop
distributed file system htfs openstack
Swift Amazon S3 and Cassandra
it allows you to store and process data
in real time across various clusters of
computers using simple programming
constructs
Apache spark is designed to accelerate
analytics on Hadoop while providing a
complete Suite of complementary tools
that include a fully featured machine
learning library a graph processing
engine and stream processing
so this is how the interface of Apache
spark looks like
now let's look at the important features
of Apache Spark
stores data in the ram hence it can
access the data quickly and accelerate
the speed of analytics spark helps to
run an application in a Hadoop cluster
up to 100 times faster in memory and 10
times faster when running on disk
it supports multiple languages and
allows the developers to write
applications in Java Scala r or python
spark comes up with 80 high-level
operators for interactive querying spark
code for batch processing join stream
against historical data or run ad hoc
queries on stream state
analytics can be performed better as
spark has a rich set of SQL queries
machine learning algorithms complex
analytics Etc Apache spark provides
fault tolerance through spark rdd spark
resilient distributed data sets are
designed to handle the failure of any
worker node in the cluster thus it
ensures that the loss of data reduces to
zero